toujours michel mr exactement un coup de
gueule contre enquête exclusive et une
erreur dans ma phrase numéro 2 j'avoue
un coup de gueule contre enquête
exclusive qui reçoit présente un numéro
qui n'était pas mal ou de man sur
l'algérie l'algérie c'est la modernité
ses traditions souvent archaïques en
tout cas son manque de démocratie et il
ya une ligne youtube vous êtes déjà
partial déjà c'est faire un lancement
c'est pas pour dire ce que vous pensez
je dis pas ce que je pense c'est pas que
pas connu comme le plus grand pays
démocratique ne dit pas de bêtise c'est
mon avis voilà voilà donc et pas de
pitié non plus on a hier bernard de la
villardière est encore en tête-- une
fois de plus fait pour avoir fait un
reportage sur l'algérie complet notre
tissu a dû tout ce qui se passait là bas
une fois de plus c'est pas la peine pour
moi je trouve d'en rajouter ce soir
après jean mi vous dites que vous pensez
juste que je m'en sois présent mais il
est surtout sur le crayon du sujet de
bernard de la villardière qui rejoignent
eux tu me voilà c'est dit je vais à lyon
je vais aller faire un reportage sur
l'algérie un documentaire et je vais y
aller à fond et j'ai surtout ça a été
une catastrophe zhenghua on va regarder
un petit récapitulatif de ce qui s'est
passé hier
parce que en cause notamment l'image de
la femme algérienne décrite dans le
reportage
l'une des intervenantes la youtube star
nous explique même avoir été dupés par
la protection car à part la production
qui auraient faussé son témoignage ça a
été un déferlement toute la nuit ils
étaient entêté et bernard de la
villardière
à chaque fois on dirait qu'il le fait
exprès bien c'est même sans rigoler il
le fait exprès parce que c'est assumé
non mais c'est pas possible
à chaque fois on sait qu'il a des
problèmes avec mine de rien voilà avec
l'algérie et la tunisie et que maroc
avec il est obligé de faire des sujets
dessus continue à faire des sujets sur
les campings et le cap d'agde et
arrêtent dont bt le monde regarder pour
un français ces images n'ont rien de
choquant mais en algérie c'est tout
nouveau
avant c'était ma lieu la prestation ça a
changé petit à petit parce que les
filles de plus en plus
font ce qu'elles veulent et la société a
commencé à les accepter de l'est la
pointe
pour autant nous reste une mineure à vie
qu'est ce que tu fais quoi qu'elle fasse
elle doit demander l'autorisation à son
mari marouane
le jeune homme de 22 ans garde toujours
un oeil sur elle
vous avez l'impression de jouer quel
rôle en fait qu'à leur encadrant le
protecteur le mari lamy tout en fait
alors c'est vrai que ça a été un
déferlement aidé hier sur les réseaux
sociaux
vous allez voir vous avez énormément
réagi bossi la question c'est est-ce que
vous avez aimé cette enquête qui vivent
sur l'algérie est ce que bernard direct
encore allé trop loin et géraldine alors
effectivement jean-mi il a raison sur le
papier ça pouvait être pas mal parce
qu'ils ont ils ont annoncé en grande
pompe
on a fait deux ans dans kate on a on a
mis des caméras on a même utilisé des
journalistes binationaux pour pouvoir
rapatrier des images en france donc ok
sur papier pourquoi pas mais
effectivement le problème avec bernard
de la villardière c'est qu'il a une
fixette éditorial il veut absolument
faire entrer ces théories dans n'importe
quelle boîte j'ai ça coince
alors moi je me suis renseigné par
exemple sur les faits ça moi je me dis
mais pourquoi il continue ces sujets là
on sait très bien qu'il a un petit
problème solide et sérieuse botté par
exemple il a pris 7 c'est cette fameuse
nour qui est très populaire en algérie
mais elle a plein d'autres
il ya yumi rim à massels femmes
mademoiselle s est elle a dévoilé des
non voilées et forcément il a voulu à
nouveau à mon avis encore une fois à
stigmatiser mais en fait radicaliser son
propos est en fait ce qui est bien c'est
qu'il ya du discernement
oui quand on dit il ya ça mais il ya
aussi ça je trouvais qu'il était un peu
caricatural il ya très rarement du
discernement au chili bernès a été
tourné en juin 2010 9 à l'art d'abord là
le lay ou tu buzz là elle dit moi dans
le reportage exprimer ma fierté d'être
musulmane comme par hasard ce n'est pas
dans les propos d'elle qu'on l'a
retranscrit dans les reportages et puis
moi il ya des femmes algériennes qui
m'ont contacté aujourd'hui qui m'ont dit
mais chez nous il ya des avocates des
commerçantes des familles 800
l'émancipation de la femme avancé quand
on voit ce reportage on a l'impression
que tout recul en algérie un coin alors
que les gens se battent et essaye
d'avancer quoi la charge en permanence
chérèque y avait vu un déferlement sur
plusieurs temps moi je me dis
franchement omis dans il faut arrêter il
faut qu'il arrête de faire cela oui
qu'est ligne sur ça c'est en fait on a
beau lutter à chaque fois réclamé des
choses et ça ne se fait jamais donc en
fait on a l'impression que les gens ils
peuvent se plaindre quand ils voient des
choses et en fait moi au final
quant à bernard de la villardière qui
fait des choses comme ça ça fait que
régresser à chaque fois qu'on a des
reportages sur l'islam
les gens nous disent mais c'est pas
comme ça chez nous mais c'est pas une
image qu'on veut avoir de notre pays
c'est pas nouveau semé et je savais
quand vous regardez le reportage
je savais que j'allais les circuits
barcelona villardiens et se retient
surtout la jeune femme la chaîne
la jeune lourdes ailleurs elle est
revenue sur un an nous envoie la voix
off dit nenê les mineures à vie c'est
fou n'importe quoi elle n'est pas
mineure à vie donc rien que ça déjà dans
le propos c'est tendancieux et zeller à
1,8 à choses qui ne sont pas vraies moi
j'ai envie de me tourner vers isabey
isabelle aussi graves il adhère vous le
connaissez plutôt bien il est sûr et oui
ça on comprend alors c'est pas une
production ligne de front un oui c'est
une fois dans l'eau c'est alors messi
l'un de l'autre ce 6 mai alors que la
production s'est situé reportage moi je
n'ai pas compris la diffusion d'abord
parce qu'effectivement c'est un vieux
reportage qui a été tourné avant le
continent on l'a fait ou n'a pas fait et
je pense que c'est pas lui qui a choisi
la dalle est d'accord c'est cinq ans par
la villardière qu'on voit c'est ma mère
mais non il a fait la falsab elle ma
chérie c'est lui qui l'a fait je n'ai
pas aimé sur une image oui même si c'est
lui qui le présente ainsi des balles et
c'est lui qui me présente je trouve
surtout la moindre des précautions
professionnel quand on fait des désirs
pente h les sujets sensibles
c'est de montrer leur portable avant
personnes qui sont interrogés avaient
apprécié qu'on subit les conséquences
lui après villardière il s'est cassé 500
mari serait prévue de son mari sont même
pas avoir d des réprimandes en fait des
conséquences qui sue kim est désastreuse
surtout qu'elle dit on me reproche
d'être soumise à mon mari c'est son
manager sont assez ibos avec elle son
patron en forcément une décision il en
référé il en réfère à lui et ils ont
troqué sa comme s'ils étaient soumises
alors chaussez pourrait au moins lui
montrer montrer aux gens les reportages
à rené diffuser concernent des sujets
sensibles alors voilà c'est et voilà qu
est ce que on va voir la question ce
qu'ont annoncé les téléspectateurs
comprenez vous les critiques oui à 48,1
ce modèle noah 49 sont beaucoup plus
mitigées que nous mine de rien mais
c'est vrai que hier ça a été un bep
fermement sur les réseaux sociaux